a tutti ciao di nuovo slime telepatico
fini siamo separati dal muro davanti a
questo punto potrebbe cadere da un
momento all'altro forse potrete
assistere a qualche tragedia in questo
video comunque l'uomo tra intel e
portico però questa volta con le sfere
misteriose usiamo vari ingredienti
dentro questo sfere e dovremo cercare di
connettersi e scegliere la sfera dello
stesso colore dell'altra persona abbiamo
a cercare di fare lo slime identico
all'altra persona ci riusciremo
speriamo l'altra volta ha devoluto un
risultato abbastanza buona stranamente
se non avete visto il nostro slang
telepatico che abbiamo un patto l'altro
video andate a vederlo con questo video
oggi siamo tifo rota e team blu per chi
votate alla fine del video come sempre
li metterò il sondaggio qua in cui
potrete portare il servizio team rosa o
blu anita o un tale dinamica comunque
mettetevi comodi patatine poco
rilasciate un bel live se volete vedere
altri slight le parti si consiglia tesi
che pensate se volete che facciamo
assieme
sei pronto si sono pronto e stranissimo
non vederti non abbiamo lo schermo la
cui possiamo vederci quindi non abbiamo
idea di cosa sceglierà questo persona
chiave i turni uno alla volta
se io resto a dominare quello che ha
preso vita le faccio un punto vitale
riesce a indovinare quello che ho preso
un buon punto e alla fine vedremo chi ha
vinto in base ai punti collezionati voi
invece dovrete votare in base allo stand
più bello secondo voi allora abbiamo
l'altra cosa trasparente nella prima
scelta inizio inizia tutto ok allora
prima scelta abbiamo rosa si aspetta che
stai facendo non ricuperando dalle
piazze fino allora prima scelta soggette
le professionale stato in connessione
delle basi per asti e quale ho scelto di
altra pallina quella blu ritenta la
verde da la giallo era l'unica che
mancavano c'era ancora la rossa la nota
nella zona arriva la rosa giallo
prendila entrambe connessione offerta
devo ancora scegliere
[Musica]
ok ho scelto rango di falli e che ha
anche papà ti manda segnali
mamma segnale ho attivato i recettori
anche il gps selezione duca casa
negativo camera io la stava andando
avanti serata l'antenna
bella questa matteo risultati
vai è ritenuta ok ricevuto è seduta
assolutamente sì ok fai la tua scelta
fatta
ok andiamo ora a mettere gli ingredienti
dentro grande sperando che siano deboli
ingredienti visto che le palle sono
misteriose il 30 dei seggi non sono
simile a mi sono decisa quindi tocca a
me adesso sì che possa scegliere
qualunque colore delle palle e allora ho
scelto bluceleste e verde blu celeste
quindi piccola però aspetta che non
coloro hanno scelto io e te che le
frecce da papi ok se leo non guarda
dentro la sfera
non sto chiudendo perché hai scelto ma
sono possedute queste palle perché non
si è mosso da sola io non ho certo non
viene già qualcosa di vivo dentro
credo che ovviamente ma non sarà mica
una zuppa se noi tutto per zucca o
settembre valentia re ok ho scelto ai
sei domande mi insegna le mando segnale
è alzato dal termine arriva
sono troppo dai vari signora chiara ma
se troppo disturbo quando si è certo
nota da concentrati concentrati
concentrati e cento si ok per vedere
cosa è certo no fai vedere a guardare
camera ok andiamo
[Musica]
umberto i il 2008 si è bellissimo bene
perché stai facendo di non sapere niente
questo aspetto superando niente io sto
proprio vedere i colori cache al 43 andò
tutto bene sto muovendo
nell'attesa prato e fiesta
[Musica]
[Applauso]
così non è allora il rosso o arancione
ronda ok ha quindi è già certo la
premier è atteso proprio ok
devo scegliere ok ho scelto ti mando il
segnale mi mandi il segnale
[Musica]
e arrivato non certo di andare dai però
permette di meglio sostengano la
caratterista senza un tema ben messo
il tema di unicorno rimanga
e arrivato e si forte e chiaro ho
ricevuto
ok poi vedere cosa che sento questa ok
[Musica]
sì che abbiamo scelto bene
molto particolare questo su line
[Musica]
tocca a te tocca allora a questo punto
se abbiamo scelto le stesse palle
dovremo andare gli stessi colori qua
dentro ma se chiamiamo accetto anche
solo una diversa abbiamo colori diversi
quindi non possiamo più dire se il
valore all altro colore ma dobbiamo
prenderli a caso ok quindi lo prendo a
caso si ok il succo le celle mentre
tutto al caso dai ok adesso per queste
due che ho scelto mi devo scegliere un
numero e poiché ciascuna ok ma navi
insegnare ricevuto ok posso procedere
procedi
[Musica]
scotch figli ma non ho capito come
funziona lo stesso ok non mi sembravi
tanto con titolo questo a chi tocca a me
aspetta io mica son pronto ancora non
conoscesse i vini e il 9 sono né
tantomeno abbiano cos'è questo
[Musica]
devo dire che il risultato mi piace ma
non troppo è bene quindi forse è uguale
quindi siamo davvero delle pa tc
la mostra tele nosti aspetto che sta
girando un po non altobello devo dire ok
bene ultimo turno
ultimo turno l'ultimo turno abbiamo due
stacca posso azzurra è una multi colla
ok concerto speciale lo farà scegliere a
in vetta
non lo sappiamo quell'anno della vita
per le scelto molto lanterna
ok ho scelto mondo ha insegnato
non ti sento dai tanto ma andando un po
artistico manda forte ok è già entrato
solo talmente forte che il prodotto
dalla lei affetta un nome saputo niente
accesso per aprirlo senza gli 800 cosa
aprirlo asi e non lo vedo mica dai
giorno fa meglio andiamo perché un
macchiato tutto di colla dobbiamo
coprire col nuovo dal nodo mi sto
incollando tutte le vite nel suo ha
capito allora io ho poteri the ad
attivare il mio club
mentre tu continui a mettere qualche ora
di sì che bello che morto
[Musica]
come abbiamo fatto uguale non sarei
derby e che senso
niente non lo vedrai perché è brutto
dipende dai gusti per fortuna il mio
bellissimo a spini ha più diritto
venderemo evitare le parti ma chiusi a
questo punto un bellissimo prodotto è la
prima storia spetta aspetta quindi un
incastrato come cliccata bassi si
aspetta ei a scusa che bello dei malati
serio ma almeno ha un colore quasi bello
siamo già pensieri suoni
[Applauso]
[Musica]
informare il braccio di rischiare non
pagare tutto qua
quasi fatto tu come stai
io la vita per cadere un muro adottando
sono quasi pronto viene ucciso un po
tema halloween che tu pure molto bene
siamo quasi
abbiamo perso i pezzi nel frattempo
risoluzione per l'under ti stai perdendo
i pezzi ed ora però no ma io lo stimo
grazie nel terreno perche ci sono quasi
a un attimo ancora perché un pochettino
appiccicosa stai perdendo molti pezzi
chissà chi vincerà dà per sicura anch'io
ripeto come prima ti ho dato la
soluzione per lenti bicarbonato ho
pensato bene metto un po di più così poi
non devo richiedere la nato non ha
funzionato
ok io sono pronto capello io mi perdo
qualche persona bene ormai è qualche
pezzettino accaduto perché normale che
cadono quando sono così stretti e allora
ti prepara mondiale sono pronto
ok tagliamo il duro fronti si guardi
simile premi che il mio per fortuna
recuperato per confisca
il mio più rosa il mio primo era ten the
year hp sembra verde via più totale
credo anche a cambiarlo perché poi che
capigliatura diversa quella micol unione
preparo con la celeste preso piccolo
pero l'unico che abbiamo preso uguale
hanno pure questa poi ho preso io ho
preso il vert tu no è un giochino volevo
prenderlo altrimenti avrei lasciato di
band ai propri compagni pratica a me
capita perché lei è anche a te è infatti
per quello che diceva che sembra sempre
molto intervallo si parecchio anno
mentre il mio è quello di evitare il
maxi bag di miu miu anche i brillantini
mariner datec lei non usate le palline
dello splash dai malviventi
tutte al cielo uscito verde dopo sul
processo di barabba della pnl sera
brutti vince vitale in a2 veramente duro
sì forse troppo attivo che colore strano
ma sembrano bene poi tu hai avuto i
primati è stato anche il fisco e che
guarda caso tutto aperto di più il suo
vero io allora che ho visto ho dato x me
mi piace di più il mio viene di questa
libertà mi ha detto che era filato
[Musica]
pilastro poi si è dissolto allora vi
lascio qui sondaggio in cui potete
votare subito io team rosa o teorizzo
vitale team
un percorso di costi non scivolare sì
basta più quattro cartellini
potete cliccare per vedere gli altri
altri video nelle nostre sale
i nostri video divertenti tricase quella
che preferite e buona visione
ciao